هي ليست مجارده انتخابات لتجديد نصف مقاعد
الكونغرس الامريكي بل هي لحظه فريقه في
الحياه السياسيه للولايات المتحده
فلنتائجها وقع كبير على المستقبل القريب
لامريكا
ريح تغيير ان هبت فانها ستطال اولا سياسته
جوبايدن خلال السنتين المتبقيتين له في
ولايتها فاجنداته قد تواجه بعض العراقيل
كما ان المسار الديمقراطي على المحاكم
التشكيك في نزاهه الانتخابات من طرف
مناصرها الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب وهو ما يعني ان الانتخابات الحاليه
هي امتحان للديمقراطيه فاما اعاده
الاعتبار للمشهد الديمقراطي في البلاد او
تكريس الشكوك التي تتزايد شيئا فشيئا من
شان الانتخابات الحاليه ان تلقي بظلالها
ايضا على العمليات الانتخابيه المقبله على
المدى المتوسط والقريب حيث قد يعمل فريق
الجمهوريين بشكل خاص على بلوره لاعاده
تشكيل الدوائر الانتخابيه وتغيير
الاجراءات الانتخابيه على مستوى الولايات
عامل المهيمن اخرج على الانتخابات النصفيه
ذات اهميه خاصه فهي تعد مؤشرا حقيقيا لرسم
خريطه حظوظ المرشحين للرئاسيات القادمه
سواء تعلق الامر بالرئيس الحالي بعدنا او
السابق ترامب او غيرهما فهي وحده لقياس
مدى شعبيه كل حزب وقدرته على جذب اصوات
النخبه وسام الذهبي العربي